Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett,
this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna be
♪ Talking 'bout my generation ♪
We're gonna be talking
about generations, y'all.
We're gonna be talking about
what generation we come from,
which might be in some dispute,
we're gonna to be talking
about the generation
that most of our employees come from,
we're gonna be talking
about the generation
that our kids are a part of,
our parents.
Okay boomer.
We're talking about.
The dynamics, man
We're talking about Xennials.
Well, Xennials would be,
you got millennials, you got Generation X,
you got Xennials, which is in between,
you got Generation Z.
Which is supposedly us, Xennials.
I don't know.
I can tell.
Okay.
No.
You can tell me, or you
can tell I don't know?
Kiko did some some
boop, de boop, boop, boop, boop research,
kind of pulled up some
different perspectives
that people have on, like, what makes,
first of all,
we're gonna kind of go through
what the generations are,
just if you need a refresher on that,
but we're also gonna talk about
what makes an Xennial, an Xennial.
And I think it's kind of remarkable,
once you start thinking about
what makes us not really
a part of Generation X
and not really a part of the millennials,
and it'll bring up some
memories, I'm sure.
Some trauma?
And also
the way that we're seeing the
relationships in our lives.
Okay, I'm up for that.
But I wanna talk about the
fact that you got a haircut.
I did.
Which was
obviously not self-imposed.
Yeah, this is a more drastic cut
because this is a professional cut.
Yesterday, I experienced
someone else cutting my hair
for the first time since.
Since COVID.
Since March.
Yeah.
Boy, it's strange
when something's been
out of your life so long
and then it's like, wait,
this is back in my life.
Now, it was weird 'cause it was, I mean,
Anna, who would always
come in and cut my hair,
some people call her Annalyn.
I just call her Anna,
'cause I ain't got time for long names
when you accept the shorter version.
Well, you know, one of the
sweetest people on the planet.
She is.
Super talented and very gracious,
and she enjoys working
with us, even though.
She works on much bigger
and better things.
She works on "American Horror Story",
she's working on "Dear White People".
Yeah.
She's got her hands in
lots of places.
Lots of people's heads.
Just got back from her homeland of Guam,
where she was hunkered
down because of COVID,
so she wasn't even here,
but I was like, trimming my own hair.
But yeah, she came up,
we set up a tent outside,
I'm wearing a mask, she's wearing a mask,
she's been thoroughly tested,
I've been thoroughly tested,
let's make this happen!
She said she gets tested,
six times a week.
I mean, we get tested once a week.
She gets tested six times a week.
Six is a lot.
Well, she's working on two different shows
that require three tests a week
and so she just, you show
up and they test you,
so she ends up getting
tested six times a week.
There's only seven days in a week.
She might be the most
tested person on earth.
What's that doing to her nasals?
Some people are being
tested daily, I guess,
but she's basically being tested daily.
Imagine being constantly
swabbed in the nose.
Constantly would get old.
But daily, I've gotten used to it, man,
we get tested weekly and got tested today.
Sit down in the tent,
one person at a time,
just a guy in full protective garb
shoving a,
basically a bottle brush, up my nose.
It's a cotton swab.
It's not, it's a bottle brush.
You're not making eye contact with it.
Oh, I never look at it.
It's not a pipe cleaner.
Well I'm telling you what it feels like.
It is a long Q-tip.
It's a pipe freaking cleaner.
It is a long Q-tip, it is a cotton swab.
Yeah, but it's got.
Nothing else on it.
It's got something abrasive
on the end of it.
It doesn't
have anything abrasive on it.
I'll look at it next time.
Okay.
Are you telling me, do you watch it go in?
Yeah, when somebody's about
to stick something in my nose,
I look at it.
I mean, who knows?
He could get confused,
he could get mixed up,
he could put yours in mine.
I mean, we got a professional
outfit doing this.
That's not gonna happen.
It's super professional.
First of all, watching it go in your nose
has nothing to do with yours and mine.
I would be able to tell if it was wet,
whoa, whoa, yeah, you got a wet one!
Hold on, hold on, this is not a fresh one!
Oh God.
You're not gonna know that.
If he's double-dipping?
Yeah, he's not,
again, I'm not trying to cast dispersion
on the person who's doing this for us.
He's double dipping from my
right nostril to my left.
Do you have a conversation with him?
I've just quit talking,
I say good morning.
I say, good morning, here we are again,
sometimes I'll say here we are again.
I feel bad that I've kind of,
there was one week
where we kind of talked,
he saw me pull up.
Small talk.
In my new car.
And he was like, oh,
let's talk about that.
No, he don't talk, it's all business.
I think he leaves it up to you,
but I'm just like, he's so efficient,
it happens so quickly
that I'm just like,
mornin', how you doing?
He's like, good,
and then it's just like,
and I'm like, thank you,
and then I get up and go.
He does the second swab so rapidly
after the first insertion,
that I'm reacting to the first one
after the second one's done,
so he's got a good technique.
'Cause my head shakes
and you don't want your head to shake
when you got a bottle cleaner.
The first test I ever
got was at my doctor,
my regular doctor,
and they had a parking lot kind of thing.
Yeah, roll your window
down, stick your nose out.
That guy, not my doctor,
but a doctor at my doctor's.
Went deep?
Not only did he go deep,
first of all, I was like,
now I have a deviated septum,
the right nostril is
pretty difficult to get in.
Oh gosh.
But my left nostril is
susceptible to bleeding
if you irritate it.
You told them all this?
Yeah, 'cause he was like, okay,
well I'll try on the right.
And he goes into the right,
and this is back in
the early days of COVID
the testing was deeper and more invasive,
and now I think they've
learned that, okay,
we just gotta get in there a little bit.
But he shoved it in there
and he hits whatever the deal is,
you know, I've never broken my nose
but a majority of the population
has a deviated septum, naturally.
You could feel him hit something?
He's hitting the septum that's deviated
and he can't get through
'cause it's, you know, it
is not a bottle cleaner,
it is a Q-tip.
I think he needs to get a hammer
and start chiseling.
And so he's like, oh, can't
do it, can't get in there,
pulls it out, goes in the left side,
and I swear he hit my brain.
Oh yeah, yeah,
first one.
It was so far back,
it went all the way through
and was in the back of my throat,
and then he said
"Okay, now that I'm in there,
I have to turn it slowly
for seven seconds."
Yeah, I had one of those.
Seven seconds!
They don't do that anymore.
So when dude out here,
does he hit your septum?
I don't think so.
He doesn't go deep
enough to hit the septum.
That's what I'm saying,
I don't think they do that anymore,
I don't think they go as deep anymore.
I wonder if he's deviated from the.
It's uncomfortable.
Procedure enough to not
hit the deviated septum.
Well, I had a ENT one time
when I was dealing with
my onset of allergies
a couple of years ago
and I was like, I don't know
what's going on with my throat,
the first time we went on tour
and I was having all those throat issues,
and it was allergies and I
hadn't diagnosed myself yet.
He was like, okay, let
me look at your throat
and he did the thing
that you got done at the plastic surgeon,
when we made the commercial
in Newport Beach.
A scope.
So he went into my right
nostril, the deviated one,
and I guess, because
the camera's flexible,
it went around the deviation
and he got back there.
Okay.
And examined things,
everything was fine, don't worry.
It is a disconcerting feeling.
But a year later, I
went to a different ENT
as a follow-up, but a follow-up
with a different doctor.
Okay.
He couldn't get in,
he could not get through the deviation.
I think some people have the courage
to just do that extra,
just really get it in there.
We're losing people,
we're losing people.
And some people don't.
Including me,
but the haircut.
Yeah, let's talk about that.
It was nice, but, you know.
It's a good hair cut.
My hair had gotten so bushy
that I was just doing
maintenance on the bush.
And the bush on the sides
was getting pretty bushy.
Everywhere, it was getting really big,
but I just don't like doing
a drastic cut, myself,
because, you know, on the
back it's all guesswork.
Yeah.
She's a pro, she did a great job,
but it's not just a trim,
it's a little bit more
and I just have flashbacks
to when I was a kid,
and whenever you'd go in
and get a haircut as a kid,
it would be so drastic
and be like, oh gosh,
I have to go to school the next day
and it looks so different.
I hate it when people are
like, d'you get a haircut?
It's like, you either
know I did, or you didn't,
don't ask me if I got a haircut, just say.
Nice haircut.
I think sometimes people are
legitimately curious though.
D'you get a haircut?
You styling it differently
or is it just cut?
It's still longer than it ever used to be,
but it now feels so much shorter
and I'm in this transition period
where I'm trying to get used to it.
What you've done,
my assessment of it is that
it is the same length on top
that you used to reset at,
but it's a longer length on the
side than you used to reset.
Yeah, I don't want it to
be too short on the sides,
I want it to be a little
longer on the sides.
Well, but you have slowly gone away,
I mean, I don't know when it was,
but it's one of those things
that you watch old episodes
where we see ourselves in montages
and we're like, whoa.
It was so tight,
so tight on the sides.
There was a point
where you went full,
I don't even know what
you would call it, but.
You could see skin on the sides.
Yeah.
And I don't like that.
It was getting almost,
it's almost like a Nazi cut, honestly.
What?
No it wasn't.
I don't look back at montages
and say, damn, I look like a Nazi, what?
No, but I'm saying, the Nazi dudes,
they have a haircut
where they do it really
really short on the sides.
It never got to that point.
I'm saying you were approaching that,
if you had actually gotten there,
I would've said hey man, look,
there's a bunch of racists on the internet
that look like this,
but you never got there,
but I'm saying you got close.
But people know that's not who you are,
so I didn't have to say anything.
I'm not doing that anymore,
but now, especially with your
hair being so long and shaggy,
I'm kind of taking that
into account, because.
You don't wanna be too buttoned up?
The kids saying it's the
businessman and the boy
on that old react video,
they called you the
businessman, called me the boy.
Now I don't want it to be the
caveman and the businessman.
But I don't think you can do anything.
Caveman and the boy.
I think that what I have going on
is so far removed
from anything that we would
have considered normal.
But it makes anything,
this fresh cut makes me seem clean cut
which, in a normal situation,
I would just seem
like I don't have a
really clean cut haircut.
Like if I had the haircut
that you were talking about before,
that would be too big of a contrast
between the two of us.
I don't know,
maybe it would be what we need.
Maybe you should go full newscaster.
I'm not going newscaster.
No, what if you went as tight,
what if it was like hair sprayed
and it was a little bit lower,
and it kind of swooped?
What if it was like,
you could see the part,
what if you just went full,
like, this is so locked in?
That would be an interesting
sort of contrast,
you might wanna do that one day.
I don't want to do that.
You might do it before you die,
I might do it before you die.
You can do it.
Before you die.
Before I die, yeah, I
want you to clean up.
Well, one thing I didn't ask Anna,
that I was gonna ask her
and I was kind of just gonna see
if she was gonna say something about it,
because when I saw her yesterday,
when she came in to cut your hair,
I had my hair tied up
and, of course, me not cutting
my hair for over a year,
the person who has cut my hair,
if my hair is going to be
cut, is gonna say something,
she was like, your hair, wow.
And so, because I know
how she thinks about hair,
I know that if I had made the
decision to grow my hair out
and COVID had not have happened,
and she had continued to be around,
she would have said, now,
when you grow your hair out,
you still need me to cut
your hair as you grow it out,
because for the sake of
the health of the hair
and for thickness and all this stuff.
Yeah, I get it,
so you thought she was
gonna say something?
I thought she might say, you know.
You could still use a trim.
You could use some thinning
or whatever it was.
Or a trim.
A trim, or, like I noticed the other day.
Get rid of the burnt ends.
I don't know if you can see this,
but I don't think that this
is really supposed to happen,
'cause all my hair was like it was
and then I just started growing it,
and no attention to anything, right?
And so if you see this.
That's like the mullet area.
There's a mullet area that's way longer,
just because the hair's lower
on my head than this area.
But I think
that she would be like, let's
get that all the same length,
but she didn't say anything,
so I didn't say anything.
But if she did, what would you have said?
I would've been like, I'm cool, I'm good.
Yeah, you can't do anything to seem like.
There's no corrective measures
that can be made to the hair.
You can't do anything to try
to make it seem prettified?
Right.
'Cause, trust me, when you put it in that,
oh, you know what, I'm
staying out of this,
that's actually what I decided,
you're trying to draw
me in to give an opinion
and I'm not doing it.
Oh, I don't want an opinion.
I know you're not, but you are,
but you're tempting me and I'm not,
that's the thing I've committed to doing,
is I'm not going to talk about your hair.
Here's the only opinion
that I'm interested in from
you, as it relates to my hair,
is when you think that,
do you think that there
would come a moment
in the next months or years
in which you would be like, hey,
I think you should cut your hair?
Like so, for instance,
if I went full
Rapunzel.
Or has there been a point?
Has there already been a point?
I don't know, you know,
everybody's got a terminal length,
do I go to terminal length?
I mean, that could be
years away, I don't know.
I mean, somebody messaged me on Twitter,
not messaged me, but
just added me on Twitter,
and said, she was like, I'm sorry to say
my mom has stopped watching
"Good Mythical Morning"
because of your hair.
Really?
She's like, she even met you
when you came to so-and-so town
and showed me the picture,
put the picture of us with
them, a mother and a daughter.
She's like, my mom will not watch the show
because of your hair.
So the only reason she
was watching the show
is because of your previous hair?
I guess,
or whatever's happening with your hair
is not enough to keep her around,
but maybe now that you
got a professional cut,
she'll come back,
maybe that's enough
for her to overlook
whatever she doesn't like
about my situation.
Pulling your weight.
So you're saying
that you're not gonna to tell me
when you think I should cut my hair,
and that you would have already told me
if opinions were open?
See, you're tempting me, man.
I haven't told you what
I've thought about your hair
or what you've done to it,
because that was the decision I made,
I'm just staying out of it.
Oh, you made a decision?
Yeah, I was like, you know
what, I'm gonna stay out of it,
he's got his reasons, you know, who am I?
Okay, nothing has compelled me
to say, listen, I gotta intervene.
Oh okay, well there's still time for that.
But yeah, I reserve the right to intervene
for the good of the brand.
But I'm not happy with
getting a haircut, myself,
it's like I didn't know
what to do with it,
but I hate getting a haircut,
that's why whenever I used to come,
it would just be like this maintenance,
a little bit of trim, I don't
like that type of change.
Are you saying that it was on the table
for you to do something new and different?
No, just not to cut as much.
But you didn't cut as much.
I feel like I still cut too much,
I don't like what's
happening on the sides.
What do you want to
happen on the sides, more?
A little more, yeah.
Just let it grow.
A little shaggy, yeah it's
headed in the right direction.
Let it grow, I mean, it's
longer than it has been.
Yeah, but not as long as it was yesterday.
You know, we could
continue to talk about this
for the entire hour,
but we're not gonna do that,
we're gonna move on to even
more interesting things.
But first, you know what?
You got a phone, you'd like
to be able to stand it up
so you can watch things on it
without holding it.
Or hold it,
like hold it suspended.
Yeah, anti-gravity.
Get a pop socket from mythical.com.
Yeah, we got those now,
we've had 'em for a while, actually.
Sometimes when I go in
for physical therapy,
she lays me down on my back
and then she does some
neck adjustment here,
'cause I'm working on this.
The first rib situation
is a little too tight,
it's under the collar bone and it goes.
There's a rib up there?
Yeah, the first rib.
So she's working on that
and sometimes she'll get
to talking about something,
and she's the one that said.
Party?
My rib needed to be invited to the party.
Sometimes she'll be
talking about something
and she'll show me a picture
or a video from her phone,
and I'm looking up at the ceiling,
and all of a sudden,
I'll see a hand with a phone come over.
And then she's showing me something
and I'm like, she's gonna
drop this phone on my face,
but then I realized
she got a pop socket.
She had a pop socket.
Has she got one of ours?
No, but she needs one,
I gotta give her one.
Can you pay her in pop sockets?
Yeah, yeah.
Like coins?
I'll be paying you in pop sockets.
Come out like a bag of coins
and it gets a lot bigger.
So if you wanna suspend your
phone over someone's face
while they're receiving
physical therapy, then.
Only one place to go.
Get a Mythical pop socket.
All right, so we're gonna dig
into the generations here.
So again, let's just go through
what the generations are.
There was a comment from a Mythical Beast
that got us thinking about this,
I don't think we have that anymore, sorry.
Was there?
We'll credit it on the
video right down here,
the video version's gonna
shout that person out,
we don't have it in front of us.
Quick breakdown of the
generations, just for refreshing,
or maybe this is introducing
it to you for the first time.
According to the Pew Research Center.
Pew, pew, pew, pew!
There's a whole research center,
they're constantly beep-a-de-beeping.
that's what they do.
Yeah, they sell it to marketers
who sell it to brands.
I gotta tell you that I did not know
that the generation before boomers,
which my parents are
technically a part of.
Busters?
Is the silent era.
Oh, that sounds sad.
Born 1928 to 1945, so they are 75 to 92,
so my parents are just in that generation
on the younger side.
Okay.
I don't have any information about them,
but they're silent, it makes sense.
Yeah, they wouldn't give
it to you if you asked.
Yeah.
Next one's boomers.
Boomers, we know the
boomers as 1946 to '64.
So tell me how old they are now?
Between 56 and 74.
Okay.
So your mom is a boomer, she's
not as old as my parents.
Your dad is a boomer,
your parents are boomers.
Yeah.
I always thought
I would've just called my parents boomers,
but they're actually just outside of it.
Here's a couple of facts about them,
they grew up as television
expanded dramatically,
changing their lifestyles,
and connections to the
world, in fundamental ways.
Oh.
They live to work,
their self-worth is their worth ethic,
loyal to their employer,
competitive, goal
centric, process oriented,
focused, disciplined, need
to know they are valued,
wanna make a difference.
Hopefully retired at this point?
Yeah, that's how they thought.
Not really having to work, hopefully.
And they, the population boomed
after, what, World War II?
Yep.
So that's where the boom comes from,
it's a population boom.
And it was the largest.
Come back from war, you're
completely traumatized,
you don't know what to do with yourself,
so you make babies and you
hope that makes it better.
Until a year ago, this was
the largest generation,
most people in America were boomers,
bigger than any other generation
until 2019.
So, second boomers?
And I'll tell you who that
was that replaced them,
of course, Generation X,
which we are, technically, a part of,
this is people born between '65 and 1980,
so they're between 40 and 55.
Okay, so we're the front-sided Gen X.
I don't wanna get into the
details of the generations
until we come back and start explaining,
I think it's gonna be
a better conversation,
that's Generation X.
Okay.
Then you got millennials.
When I think about Generation X,
I think about alternative rock.
I think about Eddie Vedder.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah, Nirvana.
Yeah, actually, when I
think about Generation X,
I picture Eddie Vedder
with a flannel shirt on.
Okay, cargo shorts.
Yeah.
Backwards hat.
Yeah,
and I've always felt a little
disconnected from that,
like that's not me,
which is interesting, as we'll get into.
Millennials, born between '81 and '96,
so they're between 24 and 39
and we're just on the outside of that,
and I definitely, the interesting thing is
when I think of a millennial.
Yeah.
I don't think of myself.
No.
I think of many who work for us, you know?
Okay, and then you've got
our children, Generation Z,
born between '97 and 2012.
So all of our kids are in
Generation Z, all five of them,
your three, my two,
are between eight and 23.
Gen Z.
And then you got,
what we're calling or
what is being called,
Generation Alpha.
Oh, the next one, the next one's out?
Basically, early 2010s and onward.
You don't have to start
talking about them yet, though,
you don't have to really
talk about them yet,
they haven't become
fully fledged people yet.
Yeah.
And then, okay,
and now you've got.
Generation Alpha.
You've got the generational cuspers,
the generation cuspers,
this is people who are born in the cracks
between the generations.
Again, this is all just
observational stuff
based on trends.
Right.
There's no math in this.
There's not a hard switch,
so if you're on the cusp.
There's no real science in this.
Okay.
But,
I think that there's
something really interesting
about the difference between
the Xers and the millennials,
and why we could be considered,
what they call an Xennial,
which is between '77 and '83,
I'm born in '77, you're born in '78.
Xennial.
My wife's born in '80, your wife's in '78,
so we're all right in that group.
So it's a subset of Gen
X, or does it cross over?
Well, Xennial means
some X, some millennial.
Oh yeah, what's the crossover again?
'77 to '83.
Okay.
So '80 would be the cutoff point,
so it's around 80.
Okay.
Now, all right, let's talk about this,
I'm gonna come over here
to the Xennial breakdown.
'Cause I think, for us,
we've interacted with culture
because of our jobs and our
relationship with YouTube,
and internetainment,
we've kind of, we've aged ourselves down,
we've done a lot of
work from the beginning.
When I say internetainment,
I mean streaming video, YouTube,
and all those other platforms
that were competing with YouTube,
we were committed to being
to being an active part
of that development, that revolution,
and I think that's a big factor for us.
I think you're over personalizing it,
because I think that while
that's true of us in our jobs
and the thing that we decided to do,
we got a job in social medias, actually.
But I think that the reason
that this is gonna be applicable
to people who are plumbers,
they don't have to be YouTubers,
is because the way that
social media and technology
has impacted everyone's life,
that's the interesting
thing to explore here.
Yeah, but I think about if you're 45,
let's see, what's the oldest you can be
and be considered, 45?
43, '77.
Okay, 43,
a 43 year old plumber,
I just don't think that they use YouTube.
I think that many of them do, I disagree.
Well, Facebook and Instagram.
But let's talk about the cutoff,
the thing that makes makes
the cutoff so interesting
and makes me, personally,
not feel at home in either place, right?
So, and like I said, Kiko
gathered all this information
and I kinda synthesized it down into this,
I'm just kinda taking a couple of points
and dropping them into one.
And that, basically,
what defines an Xennial
is your adolescence was social media
and largely mobile phone free,
but the onset of your adulthood
coincided with social media
and widespread mobile phone usage, right?
So as you were becoming an adult,
as you were becoming independent.
That's when you first start texting.
I got engaged and got a mobile
phone for me and my wife,
all in the same week.
Oh.
So we're getting married,
now we have to have mobile phones.
Can it have that push to talk technology?
I never did the Nextel thing.
Can I have the big Nextel?
Never did it.
Yellow and black, and bloop, bloop!
that's what I had.
But the other thing that was happening,
is at the same time
that we were experiencing a
new level of connectivity,
both through our phones
and through the internet,
and the way that the
internet was rapidly becoming
just, a part,
like, again, when did you
get your first email address,
when you showed up at NC State, right?
Just like I did, rjmclaug@eos.ncsu.edu,
don't send an email to it
'cause you'll probably
get it returned to you.
But, so we were connected to the internet,
now, some kids, the rich
kids, had a computer at home,
we didn't get that.
Yeah, like Trent.
Trent had a computer computer at home.
Had a computer in high school.
So he's chatting in high
school, parents didn't do that.
Talking shit in chat rooms.
I did go into his room
and get in the chat rooms
and talk shit to people,
I don't know why my first
inclination was to troll
when I went into a chatroom.
Well that's because that's what he did,
so that's what he showed
you, you could do.
Right, I thought that was the
limit of the possibilities.
It was fun for him.
So you got
this connectivity.
He also had a bathroom.
In his room.
In his room,
well, not in it, he had his
own bathroom connected to it,
he had a freaking master bedroom, bath.
His room was so big.
His room was so big,
he had a couch in his bedroom.
My room and your room,
I don't know whose room was smaller,
but both of them were very tiny.
Your room was smaller.
And you had a bathroom,
it was the guest bathroom.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I had a Jack and Jill.
You didn't have a Jack and Jill,
a Jack and Jill goes to another bedroom,
you had a guest bathroom
that could be entered, exit.
I had a Jack and exit.
Yeah, it could be entered
from the hallway.
Well, I guess,
that is how I used it in high school.
No, I would enter from my bedroom
and then there would be another door
and I'd exit out that door,
and I could go out another
door into the carport.
Right, yeah.
I don't know where we
were going with that.
You didn't even have a carport, my friend.
No, first of all, you had a brick house.
Yeah.
That had a car port
and you had your own
bedroom, I mean bathroom,
I had to share a bathroom with my brother,
my room was super tiny,
in fact it was actually,
it had a slant in it
that I couldn't even
stand up in half of it.
Yeah, I said your room was smaller.
And we didn't have a garage or a carport
and we had vinyl siding.
Vinyl siding, you took
a lot of pride in that.
But we had a second story
and we live closer to the country club,
and so it felt richer.
You had steps.
It felt like, I can see the country club,
so we feel rich.
You had a deck, I didn't have a deck.
You had a courtyard, almost.
I had a concrete patio, I had a slab.
Oh yeah, yeah, I was thinking
about your other house,
where you had the nice courtyard.
Yeah, but I'm talking post-divorce.
You had a big deck, but you never.
Spent time on it?
Spent time on it.
What are you talking about?
I spent all kinds of time on that deck.
No you didn't, when I
would go out on that deck
it would be covered in tree refuse.
Well they didn't do a great
job of cleaning it up,
but I went out there a lot.
Acorns and twigs.
My dad grilled out there.
It was dilapidated, man.
You didn't know what you had.
I think you're
remembering it late in the cycle.
A tree fell on it, one time,
and they left it that
way for much too long.
Well that should tell you something,
yeah, see?
It was neglected.
But see, that's why we're Xennials, man,
because our parents let
trees fall on the deck
and just left it.
Here's the thing,
not only did this sense
of connectivity happen
as you were becoming an adult,
which, we'll explore what that feels like
and what that means,
but also, the feeling that
we were no longer safe,
happened when we were adults.
9/11, for most Americans,
represents the moment
in which you were like,
whoa, whoa, hold on.
I grew up thinking that the chances
of something outside of
our country affecting us
was literally foreign,
it was like, this can't happen,
what are you talking about?
We're totally safe and protected.
9/11 happened, it changed
security around the world,
but for Americans,
there was lots of places in the world
they were already like, yeah,
welcome to the party, guys,
it's not safe,
but for us, it was like,
hold on, I just got married,
I got married in June of 2001,
9/11 happened September of that year.
So you're thinking you've moved
into this part of your life
where you're thinking
about starting a family
and bringing children into a world
that no longer feels safe and secure.
And so I think that those two things
are what makes Xennials feel
like they don't connect,
'cause millennials, of
course it's not safe,
they knew that from the beginning,
9/11 happened when they were kids,
they've grown up in the
midst of a never ending war,
so violence is just an accepted part
of the way the world works.
But also, that violence and
exposure to it is enhanced
because of the connectivity
that they had as kids,
they got cell phones as kids,
they're on the internet,
they're fluent in internet connectivity
from the very beginning,
so they see it all happening.
They have friends
in other countries.
Right.
Because of video games.
And we
may have had a pen pal through school,
but they didn't do that
at Buies Creek Elementary.
And it does make me think,
is there a pre and post-COVID thing
that's gonna happen with the.
Alphas?
Well, with our, what are our kids called?
Zs.
Yeah, Generation Z.
Yeah, I'm sure that's impacted
them in some way, yeah,
because, hate to break it to you,
but COVID-19 is just the
beginning of global pandemics
happening on a regular basis.
And unfortunately, there's just,
I was gonna get into the
climate change of it all,
but it's just not acute enough
to speak of it that way.
Yeah.
It is for some people in some places.
Right.
Dependent on the
connections that you make,
yeah, but for COVID, I
mean, I think about Lando,
the youngest of both of our kids,
as an 11 year old,
he's gonna process things as,
I know what it was like for
things to be taken away,
my school to be taken away,
for my friends to be taken away
and he's rolled with it,
but it's absolutely gonna stick with him.
Oh yeah.
And for that to happen when you're a kid,
things impact you
in a completely different way.
It's just like oh,
for kids in 9/11, it's like oh,
the world is a dangerous place,
and it's a replay of that.
But it still felt,
9/11 still felt distant, though,
as somebody who was in
rural North Carolina
it was like, well, this ain't
going to happen in Fuquay,
but it felt
too close for comfort.
I was working at IBM,
at the time,
the research triangle park,
there was so much technology focused there
in, kind of, a Silicon Valley kind of way,
that there were active discussions
about not going to work
because it could be a terrorist target,
so we were talking about
not going to the office
for that reason
and it really changes your thinking.
But, as a kid, I think it changes a lot,
I also think with the COVID
of it all, for our kids,
also translates more
directly into politics.
Of course, with Generation X,
with the experience of 9/11,
everything was much more
partisan, as a result of that.
There was an understanding of politics
through the lens of 9/11
and now, I think, for our kids,
there's an understanding of politics
through the lens of COVID,
because it's so partisan.
Right.
Versus, when we were growing up,
politics was just, we
would have mock elections
and it would be cool
to pretend we were voting for president,
but we didn't feel the impact
of a decision the governor made
have any direct impact
on you, as a person.
And the combination of those things,
the combination of feeling less safe
and then the awareness
of what contributes to feeling less safe
because of the access to information.
I talked about it in my
deconstruction story,
that the biggest thing that impacted me,
and this is impacting lots of people
who come from, sort of,
any kind of ideology, any
sort of religious ideology,
political ideology,
that you were raised in a
certain set of principles
that may or may not
necessarily reflect the truth,
but they are the truth, capital T,
to you and your community.
And for most of human history,
you've been able to maintain an adherence
to that capital T truth
for your entire life,
without it being challenged or examined.
So you point to the internet.
Unless you go to get a graduate degree
in a particular thing, but yeah.
College was really that
place where it's like, well.
And I'm talking less about college
and I'm saying that now you get access
to that level of information,
just by going on the internet.
We've got a friend who
did not go to college,
who I consider my most educated friend,
because that information is
available online, at this point,
you gotta be good at navigating that,
but I think that
that, sort of, was the beginning
of my personal deconstruction.
But I think that that is what,
I was doing some reading
as a lot of people see millennials,
and I have been guilty of this, on my own,
millennials as entitled, right?
They seem entitled,
they expect too much and they
don't wanna work as hard,
and I don't necessarily
think that that's true,
but I think they have that reputation
and I have found myself
falling into believing those stereotypes.
But I was reading this
article in Inc. magazine
and, basically, this
person was explaining this
from this perspective,
"The connected world
has empowered millennials
to take ownership,
Glassdoor and LinkedIn allow
ownership of one's career,
YouTube allows ownership of one's content,
Instagram and Snapchat allow ownership
of one's personal brand,
Netflix allows ownership of
one's content consumption."
You could go on and on,
Spotify, you got your
own music, et cetera.
"The internet has offered millennials
personalization and customization
at every turn of their lives
and now they expect the
same control at work
and in their careers."
So if you, 'cause, again,
if you go back to Generation X,
they grew up where they
had three channels,
you watch the movie that
your parents decided to rent,
you may or may not have had any say in it,
depending on the structure of your family.
I remember getting 34 channels but, still.
You had cable,
brick house, cable, bathroom.
Yeah, you didn't have cable?
No, my parents got cable
when I went to college!
I remember coming home
after my freshman year
and they had gotten cable,
I was like, what is this?
And then I was flipping
through the channels
and I got to a channel that was scrambled.
You know what, Rhett?
You had a brother.
Let me explain this.
Okay, okay.
I went back home.
I had cable,
I had Nickelodeon.
And there was a scrambled channel,
and there was a pair of
boobies in the corner.
Boobs in the corner?
And it was scrambled,
but I could hear the sounds of a woman.
Okay.
Period, that's it,
I'm not gonna say what she was doing,
but you can imagine.
And I was like, well, what is this?
Who do I call
to unscramble this?
This is when you came home
from college?
Yeah!
And then I figured out
that if you watch this particular
channel at a certain time,
they would put on a movie
that was not family friendly
and then they would scramble it,
and sometimes the guy who was
making the scramble decision
would be two minutes late,
and you'd get two minutes
of unscrambled boobies.
If they were the beginning of the movie.
And they were pretty immediate
with the particular movies
that I was watching.
As a college freshmen.
I think that was it,
it was shortly after going off to college,
they got cable and they got
the scrambled booby channel.
Yeah, you talk about the level
of access now, it's like.
Yeah, think about how
easy it is to see boobies
if you wanna see 'em now, right,
it is so different.
And so I think, I've got into discussions,
my dad is now retired,
he was a law professor for many
years, he retired this year
and I really enjoyed going home
and talking to him about the students.
Now, he had a reputation
for being a very difficult,
but very good, professor,
most students really liked him
but if you were not on top
of it, you might hate him,
because he was a difficult professor.
But he always,
from the very first time
I ever talked to him
about the exams that he would
be grading over Christmas
or around the holidays,
he was always complaining about,
it didn't matter what year it was,
he was always like, ah,
they just don't understand.
And every year it felt like they just,
they really don't understand,
he was becoming an old man
and his classes were staying the same age,
and he was seeing the generations,
through X and through
Xennials into millennials.
And we had some interesting conversations,
'cause I was like, yeah,
you might get frustrated
that your students don't seem as committed
to understanding this
particular thing in this way,
or they don't seem as capable of this,
but have you thought about
how they can actually
see things in this way,
because they're more connected
thinkers, or whatever.
The generations just change,
but I find myself sometimes
thinking like, yeah,
they are entitled,
they just think that they
should get whatever they want
but you gotta understand, you
gotta gotta pay your dues,
you gotta work for what you get.
And I think this is an interesting theory,
you live in a world of customization,
where it's just my phone,
if you pull up my phone
it represents my tastes in everything,
my digital world is curated,
my apps are curated according to my tastes
and that's a fascinating
way to think about now,
how does that not transfer over
into the way that you see the world?
Yeah, absolutely, it ironically,
and we talked about this recently,
technology enables a level of connection,
but then it's increasingly incentivized
to set up a customized
experience, just for you,
that creates insulation and isolation,
and that's happening more and
more, algorithmically, right?
We talked about "The Social
Dilemma" documentary,
we don't have to go back there,
the early internet,
it was just more of volitional connection,
now it's volitional isolation,
because that's the internet
that we experienced,
and then you realize the
ways you've been hoodwinked.
Again, I'm just thinking
out loud at this point,
becoming an adult
before you had those opportunities
for customization and isolation
through your connectivity,
'cause I think that Xennials
and even Generation Xers,
and even boomers, for that matter,
might be more susceptible to
addiction to their phones.
I know everyone's kind of
addicted to their phones,
but I don't necessarily know,
'cause I feel like the older you are,
the more it kind of snuck up on you.
If you're a Generation Xer,
it's not that you're not
completely consumed by your phone,
it just means you can remember a time
that you weren't,
but does that mean that
you're less susceptible to it?
Are our kids gonna have better tools
to manage and to deal with?
I was saying that every 43
year old plumber in America.
Has an iPhone?
Yeah, but they're not all
equally addicted to Facebook
or Instagram.
But that's why it's a cusp,
there's a gradient
and at 43, you're technically
into Generation X,
and so you may not be,
but I'm just saying
that a very high percentage
of 43 year old plumbers
have a curated digital experience,
just like anybody else.
Yeah and I'm thinking
the technology has such an
impact on who we are as people,
it has defined these
generations in a lot of ways.
I think about, even if
you look at something
like our parents, trying
to teach our parents
about using a phone, or
even using computers,
they didn't have computers in the house,
there was this distrust of it,
I'm not gonna put my banking
information on there,
I'm actually not even
gonna click on this thing,
because what if it's messed up?
And you're just like, anything
you click on, you can undo,
they didn't even understand that,
so there was this suspicion
associated with it.
But then, with our generation,
we were the ones who
had to make the decision
to start trusting
and to give more of ourselves
over to the internet,
and now the generation after us
reap the problems and the benefits
of once you do give yourself
over to it completely,
what can happen.
And then there starts to be,
I think there's now
another wave of, hopefully,
pulling back and saying, okay,
maybe I'm not gonna
accept all these cookies
and I'm gonna know how
these ads are working,
I'm gonna get beyond the magic of this
in order to know what proper
boundaries are for myself.
There's a level of skepticism
that, I think, is coming back in now.
Is that skepticism coming
from the millennials
or the Zs themselves?
I don't think so,
I think if you watch "The Social Dilemma",
most of this pushback
and sort of gut check
that's happening around social media.
Is from us.
It's happening from the
millennials and the Xennials,
and the Generation Xers who
developed the platforms.
Yeah.
And are seeing what's
happening to their children
and getting very worried
about their own children,
and just getting worried
about the state of the world.
I can't remember where I saw this,
but somebody was talking
about how there's this sort of trope
that these Generation
Zers are so tech savvy,
and this was a millennial
who was saying this,
and they were like, actually, they're not,
being able to make a TikTok video
and operate an app on your phone,
is not tech savvy, it's app savvy.
Tech savvy is knowing about
the underlying features
of the thing that you're interacting with,
knowing how to write
code, that kind of thing,
obviously, that's happening
across all generations.
But there was this
little bit of like, guys,
they're not actually that tech savvy,
they actually don't care
about specifications and technology
as much as people who are a
little bit older than them,
their apps and their phone is
an extension of themselves.
Think about the way that
you interact with your kids,
if there's a computer issue at home,
who addresses the computer
issue, you or your kids?
Who is the most equipped
to deal with something happening
with a computer at home?
Lincoln started building his own computers
and then he broke his computer,
he fried his motherboard,
and I was in the room when he did it,
it was quite a learning experience,
the sound that he made when he realized
that he had touched his
motherboard and fried it.
Did it smoke?
It didn't smoke, no, it just
ceased to work entirely.
When was this?
And he was like,
a month ago,
and he looks at me,
and I'm just like, I'm just
in here to pet the dog, dude,
I got nothing.
So he's building a PC?
Yeah, like a gaming PC,
but he had to figure that
out on his own, yeah,
but I still had to teach him a little bit,
you have to Google what just happened.
I think I just fried my
motherboard, Google that, you know?
Yeah, Locke almost got into
the computer building phase,
I don't know if I encouraged
it or discouraged it,
I don't remember,
but he thought he was gonna do that,
I was like, okay, good,
just let me know when you want to do it,
then it never came to fruition.
Lincoln's saving all his money
for the next component
now, that's what he's into.
Okay, well.
And I thought that was a good thing.
Yeah, for sure.
Because I can't help him
and he's so into it, that he's
gotta figure it out himself,
it's ironic because I worked for a company
that built computers.
When I worked for IBM
and we would refurbish
every type of computer
that they made,
they would refurbish Dell computers
and then resell them
to businesses, strange,
laptops, servers, desktops, everything,
even peripherals, peripherals.
Did you learn anything?
Is that what you're getting at?
I just designed the
conveyor belts and stuff,
computers were still so new to me.
I didn't understand,
they gotta zap the ram and then they
gotta clean the hard drive.
Gotta zap that ram.
I had no clue what this stuff was.
Well, I guess what I'm saying is,
if you have an interaction
with your parents
and I have an interaction with
my parents, about a computer,
there is clearly someone who is the expert
and someone who is not.
Yeah.
But when it comes to our kids,
I just don't think it transfers,
it's not as clean cut,
it's not like.
No it's not.
Oh, they're younger, so, therefore,
they know more.
I thought that's
what you were getting at, but you're not.
I'm saying that's not the
case, that's one of the things
We're still burdened with
IT issues, you and I,
in our homes,
is what you're saying?
Yes.
Whereas, my dad'll call me
and I literally talked
to him for 30 minutes
about his his cable internet.
You know what it's like?
When I was 16, 17, 18,
I got my first truck,
I didn't know how to fix anything in it,
but it seemed that my dad and my granddad
knew how to fix everything with the car.
And so if something
went wrong with the car,
I'd be like, well, you're
supposed to take it to a shop
and they're supposed to fix it,
or we'd get a new one,
if it's too messed up.
That's how our kids are
with computers and phones,
my phone doesn't work anymore,
well have you reset the
computer, have you restarted it?
Have you wiped your phone clean?
Things that we know how to do
because we came up
having to figure out all
of that stuff, ourselves.
Just last week.
They just want to throw
it away and get a new one.
But our parents,
our parents could fix cars.
Fix stuff, yeah.
They could fix cars in the same way.
So Locke did the same thing,
he comes to me, my phone
screen is just blinking,
it won't turn on,
and, of course, he ended
up getting a replacement
because we've got insurance on it.
But the diagnosing of that issue
and getting on the phone with tech support
is Daddy's job, right.
Again, I think that that's
a generational thing
that my parents would have made
me figure it out, probably,
and I probably should've
also done the same thing,
but I digress.
We had to learn how to change the oil,
you change the oil in
your car yourself, right?
A couple times.
At least a couple of times.
But the point
you're getting at.
I change the oil in my truck
all the time.
There's an observation that somebody made,
which is one of the things that has,
and I don't know exactly
the cutoff for this,
but for the majority of
human history your parents,
the generation before you,
was wiser
about everything that you could
be wise about, everything,
you know what I'm saying?
You were basically an apprentice
to the next generation
because technology was
introduced so slowly,
there were certain exceptions,
but it wasn't moving like it is right now,
there were not these
seismic shifts in technology
and the way that people live.
And so, as a younger person,
an older person had all the knowledge
that you could ever hope to get
was contained in a person
who was older than you,
now.
You get an app
and then all of a sudden,
this app becomes, kind of,
the center of your life.
Well, the source of the knowledge
is not a person.
Just as an example.
The source of knowledge is not people,
the source of knowledge is the internet,
it's something that you can access.
And so that's why, again,
I feel this way
about the way that I
interact with my doctor,
I respect my doctor
and I think my doctor is
schooled and intelligent,
and I'm not one of those
people that goes in
and thinks that I know more
about medical things, period, than you,
but there are times,
and I'm a hypochondriac,
so if there's a specific
thing that I'm experiencing,
I have this temptation to
believe, right or wrong,
that I might know more, are you okay?
Do I need to diagnose you?
Do I need to take you to my doctor?
I'm sorry.
It looked like you threw
water into your mouth
and forgot to swallow,
that was my experience of what happened,
it was like this.
I'm sorry,
I coughed and then water came out my nose,
I'm glad I don't have a deviated septum.
Actually, it could
protect you, in that case.
I'm just gonna wipe my face.
As I was trying to say.
Did I break your concentration?
Oh gosh.
I tend to think
that I can know more about a
specific thing than my doctor,
because I'm like, I don't know,
I don't know if he's done
this particular research
that I just did.
And I could be wrong
about that, of course,
and I'm sure it's annoying, at times,
but that's why your kids
can seem more knowledgeable
and smarter than you.
And the point that the
same article is making
is that it creates this
interesting sort of contradiction,
because, as a millennial
or as a Generation Zer,
you can have access to this knowledge,
but what you don't have,
is you don't have the lived experience
that somebody older than you has,
but you have the knowledge that they don't
about a particular thing.
That creates this weird dynamic,
especially between
employers and employees,
'cause you're like, okay,
as an employer, technically
have authority over you,
to a certain degree,
I can say that you get fired,
or I can say who gets hired,
I can change your job
description, or whatever.
But you're coming from the perspective,
this is the case with us,
it's like by design,
most of the people who work for us
know more about the thing
that they're doing for us
than we do, right, by design.
Yeah.
But we're older, we've
been doing this for longer,
and we're technically their boss,
so it just creates this,
and I don't think it's that
big of a deal in our company,
because I think we sort of just,
and this is where I think
what you were talking about
earlier, comes into play,
with us being in this particular business,
that we sort of move in the world
and function day to
day within our company,
as if we're also millennials, right?
Right, yeah.
We don't walk around like Generation Xers,
whatever that would be,
but I think that there's just this reality
that probably comes out more
in stuff like personal
discussions like this,
which is we grew up without technology,
we had to say, I'm gonna
meet you at 3:00 pm,
at the graveyard
and you just better be there at 3:00 pm,
and if you don't show up, I wait for you,
and then I go back home
and I call your landline.
That does something to you,
I'm gonna go camping tonight,
I cannot get in touch with my parents,
my parents do not know where
I'm at, I cannot call them,
I cannot contact them.
I did not wear a helmet
on the way to the river
while I was on my bike
and my parents don't care,
that does something,
when you grow up like that,
it does something to you.
They just couldn't care,
they worried, all they did was worry.
But they didn't worry that much,
they didn't worry as
much as we would worry.
If Shepherd's like, I
wanna go walk outside
in the neighborhood,
I'm like, sure, go do it,
but while he's gone
we're thinking about
the fact that he's gone.
You think my parents
were thinking about me
when I was gone?
No!
It does something to
you, I don't know what,
we're discovering it as we go.
And now with the constant
barrage of new technology,
tomorrow could present something,
and I'm not just talking about
all the TikToks of it all,
but there's kind of this spry
interaction with anything,
anything could happen that
could change everything.
Stability is, I think, is
much more of an illusion.
But from a technological perspective,
it feels like the thing that
will usher in the most change
is a physical connectivity
to the internet.
So like what Elon's working
on with the Neuralink,
which I don't even really understand,
you should know, 'cause
it's got link in the name.
I don't really understand how it works
and what the potential is,
and when that kind of thing could happen,
but I just feel like the moment
in which you're interacting
with another human
and you don't know
whether or not they're
accessing information
from their own brain,
or immediately accessing
the hive or the cloud,
again, I don't know if
that's a hundred years away
or whatever,
but I feel like that's gonna be the
seismic shift.
That'll be a great divide.
Yeah.
All right #EarBiscuits.
We'll probably be dead.
Let us know what you think.
Well, I gotta make a rec, man.
I know you gotta make a rec,
I'm just saying I wanna
know what you think,
especially if you're not an American,
we filter all these labels, are very.
Oh, for sure.
It's very Amera-centric.
Yeah, if you grew up in a place
that there was no stable government
and you didn't feel
secure from the beginning,
it's like, this is very,
and then there's lots of people
who never got access to the technology.
I guess they have it now,
if they're listening to this podcast,
but yeah, that happened at different times
in different places.
Let us know, #EarBiscuits,
what you think about that?
Give me a rec, baby, rec,
baby, one, two, three, four.
I'm gonna give you a one song rec
and this is a band that came up.
The thing I love about listening to music
with some AI built in, like Spotify,
is the suggestions, man,
you get a band that you like
and the next thing you know,
you're finding another band
that you didn't know about,
that you like.
Discover the band, Mt. Joy.
Were you using Spotify or Apple?
Have you switched?
Spotify.
You switched.
Yeah.
I'm surprised they haven't come up for me
because I have not listened
to Mt. Joy, M-T space Joy?
Mhm.
Okay.
And Philadelphia is
where these guys are from
but I think they're LA based now,
but the song that I'm going to suggest
as a nice introduction
to the band Mt. Joy,
is "Julia" or Julia, as they
say in the song, "Julia".
It's not their most popular song,
according to Spotify,
it's their sixth most popular song,
so that's actually good.
Okay, yeah, listen to the
sixth most popular song
from Mt. Joy, "Julia".
"Julia", all right,
I'm gonna add that to my thing right now.
Talk at you next week.
Add it to your thing.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms,
thanks for being your mythical best.